[Music]
house of the dragon is the upcoming game
of thrones breakable series based on
george r martin's fire and blood
a history of house targaryen set 300
years before the events in game of
thrones
the show begins filming in january 2021
and will air sometime in 2022
most likely in april set 300 years
before the events of game of thrones
the series tells a story of a turbulent
period for house targaryen
one that set sibling against a sibling
and dragon against the dragon
the point of contention who should rule
on the iron throne of course
if you'd like to know a bit more of what
the show will be about well i cannot
actually spill those beans
marin teased in his blog but you might
want to pick up a copy of two ontologies
i did with garner dezois
dangerous women and rogues and then move
on to archmaester gildane's history
firing blood
dangerous swimming includes what press
materials describe as a 35
000 world novella by martin cole the
princess and the queen
or the blacks and the greens which is
about the dance of the dragons
the vast civil war that thor westeros
apart nearly two centuries before the
events of game of thrones
the greens for the faction during the
dance of the dragons that supported the
claim of aegon the second targaryen
the rivals being the blacks who
supported the claim of her nera
targaryen
both were named for the color of their
clothes born during one tourney
rogues meanwhile includes modern story
the rogue prince or
a king's brother which chronicles their
early life adventures misdeeds
and marriages of prince daemon targaryen
considered one of the biggest rogues in
the entire history of ice and fire
finally the novel fire and blood
released in november 2018 is the first
novel of a two-part history of the
targaryens
in westeros centuries before the events
of a game of thrones house targaryen
the only family of dragonlords to
survive the doom of valyria took up
residence on dragonstone
according to the book's description on
the author's site fire and blood begins
their tail with the legendary aegon the
conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
in addition to this few casting calls
have been known i'm speaking of that of
daemon targaryen the rogue prince
confirming that the house of the dragon
will be about the dance of the dragons
the targaryen civil war miguel
sapochnick and ryan condell will serve
as showrunners and executive producers
george r martin will also serve as
executive producer
this summer it was reported that hbo has
released a casting call for george
armon's favorite targaryen
daemon targaryen a key figure from this
time period of the dance of the dragons
but who really is this george r martin's
favorite targaryen
and how big his role will be in the
upcoming game of thrones sequel
damon targaryen also known as prince of
the city lord flee bottom and the rogue
prince had many titles throughout his
life
prince sir commander of the city watch
master of coin master of loss
king of the stepstones and the narrow
sea protector of the realm
daemon was the most controversial man of
his lifetime
an audacious rogue prince and adventurer
who seemed made of good and evil in
equal measure
there was never a man so loved and so
reviled and at the same time as he was
during the dance of the dragons as the
husband of his niece rhaenyra he
supported his wife's claim
and he was considered by many the most
dangerous man in westeros
he was rhaenyra's second husband
following sir leonard valorian
and she was his third wife prince damon
was the most experienced warrior of his
time
and wielded the valyrian steel blade
dark sister a dragon rider whose dragon
was characters
daemon declared himself the king of the
stepstones and the narrow sea
daemon was a skilled warrior described
in the histories as dashing
daring and dangerous he was also
ambitious impetuous mercurial
immoral reckless and quick to take
offense he is described as being as
charming as he was hot-tempered
starting from the very beginning daemon
was born as the second son of prince
balon targaryen
and his sister wife princess elisa
targaryen
in 81ac during the reign of his
grandfather
king jaehaery's first targaryen he had
one older brother viserys
as well as one younger brother aegon
since his youth
damon's face was familiar to every cut
purse every lady of the night
and every gambler in flea bottom he was
knighted at 16
and king jaehaery's first targaryen gave
him dark's sister for his martial skill
and prowess
demon's first marriage was to lady riya
royce
but he disliked both her and the veil of
aaron during the great council of 101 ac
daemon supported the claim of prince
viserys
as it would make daemon and heir after
his brother daemon gathered a small army
when it was rumored that lord corliss
valerian was preparing a fleet to defend
the rights of his son
lehner valerian whose mother was
reigning targaryen
they would later become closest allies
demonstrate briefly as master of coin
from 103 ac until 104 ac
and master of laws for six months after
that governance board daemon
daemon was appointed commander of the
city watch of king's landing
daemon inspired loyalty with many of the
rank and file
men of the city watch improving their
armaments and equipment
he gave every man a golden cloak which
led to the guards becoming known as the
gold cloaks
daemon developed a dark reputation for
the harsh punishments
he became acquainted with the lady of
the knight named mizeria
who would serve as his mistress of
whispers in the streets of philly bottom
while daemon called himself the prince
of the city he became known as lord flee
bottom
among the residents of king's landing
daemon considered himself his brother's
heir
as viserys had no living sons and he
coveted
the title prince of dragonstone which
the king refused to grant
viserys his first wife emma arin died
birthing balon targaryen
viserys's second son the first having
died in the cradle
balon died a day after his birth however
daemon was observed in the street of
silk
making drunken jokes about the air for a
day
when the word of this reached the
grieving viserys the enraged king had
renera his daughter in daemon's niece
and future wife declared
heir in response to his ungrateful
brother's apathy
daemon left the capital in fury on
dragonstone daemon impregnated his lover
miseria
he wanted to present her with a dragon
egg the angry wizards demanded that
daemon returns the egg
and that he returns to his wife in the
vale daemon set miseria to less
but maeseria's ship sailed through a
storm in the narrow sea and maiseria
lost the child
this hardened daemon against his brother
in 106
ac daemon led an army to invade the
stepped stones in the southern narrow
sea
with the support of lord corliss
velaryon and his fleet
and with the use of daemon's dragon
characters after conquering all but two
of the islands
daemon declared himself the king of the
stepstones and an air of scene 109 ac
being crowned by corliss the sea snake
bored with ruling his meager kingdom
daemon returned to the capital king's
landing in 111 ac
during the tourney that gave the greens
and the blacks their names
he reconciled with visery's first
targaryen by offering him his
stepstone's crown
viserys welcomed his brother's return
and daemon was given a seat on the small
council
neither age or exile had changed
daemon's nature however
daemon was called with viserys's second
wife queen ellis sent high tower
and her children who had pushed him
further down in the line of succession
daemon spent hours in the company of his
niece princess rhaenyra targaryen
praising her beauty enthralling her with
tales of his adventures
giving her gifts and mocking her
stepmother and her greens
six months after his return it was
rumored that damon took renera's
virginity
prior to her 16th name day and daemon
was exiled again
demon returned to bloodstone in the
stepstones and resumed his struggle over
his baring kingdom
daemon's wife freya royce died from
falling from horse in 115 ac
daemon departed to the veil of aryan to
claim runestone
which had been rhea's seat but he was
refused by house royce
not welcoming the veil daemon turned to
a drift mark
where he laid eyes upon the enchanting
laina valerian
the beautiful daughter of his friend
lord corliss after killing in a
duoliana's betrothed
the son of the sea lord of braavos
daemon asked the sea snake for his
daughter's hand
because the marriage had been without
consent of king viserys first targaryen
daemon and elena left westeros abandoned
the stepstones
and toured the free cities they remained
in pantos for some time when they
learned that lena was pregnant
causing their daughters bayla and raina
to be born there in 116 ac
daemon wrote his brother begging lee to
present his daughters to court
to receive a royal blessing the small
council advised the king to refuse
but viserys replied the daemon is a
father now he will have changed
after giving his two daughters daemon's
second wife lena died in 120 ac
trying to birth him a son who died as
well in 120 ac
daemon married again this time to his
niece princess rhaenyra targaryen
this marriage was performed suddenly
without the knowledge of king viserys
the first targaryen
and was scandalous since neither elena
nor lane or valerian
damon's previous wife and rhaenyra's
previous husband had been dead for 6
months
according to mushroom it was daemon who
arranged the death of lenore
by paying sir corey to kill him thus
making rhaenyra available to mary
damon and rhaenyra had two sons together
prince aegon the younger born in 120 ac
and prince viserys born in 122 ac while
viserys the first targaryen had decreed
rhaenyra targaryen his heir
sir kristen cole crowned queen alice and
hightower's son aegon the second
targaryen
after viserys's death in 129 ac
the greens took advantage of being in
king's landing at the time of the death
of king viserys sent took the throne
while most of the blacks were at
dragonstone at the start of the civil
war called the dance of the dragons
prince daemon had more experience in
warfare
then all their foes combined during
rhaenyra's rival coronation on
dragonstone daemon plays the crown of
king jaehaerys first targaryen on the
head of his wife
proclaiming her the queen and claiming
himself the protector of the realm
daemon led the assault on harrenhal
capturing the ruined castle from its
castellan
after hearing of the death of his
stepson prince lucerus valerian at the
hands of his nephew
prince eamon targaryen damon through his
spymaster and
former mistress miseria hired blood and
cheese to kill a son of fake on the
second
son for a son damon abandoned harrenhal
when aemond and kristen begin marching
on the great castle with a host of
greens instead daemon flew characters
back to king's landing
and assisted rhaenyra with capturing the
city he made his niece and wife rhaenyra
the queen of the seven kingdoms
while searching for aemond and vagar who
were burning the riverlands
daemon took dragon seed nettles for a
bed mate and made their base in
maidenpool
maester norin informed daemon that queen
rhaenyra wanted nettles dead
because some dragon seeds betrayed her
daemon thanked the maester for
the warning and he and nettles separated
the next morning
daemon challenged the aemond waiting for
13 days at harrenhal
until aemond stopped burning the
riverlands to come to face him
on the 14th day just as daemon was about
to slash
a 14th mark at the heart tree in
godswood to mark each passing day
a shadow swept over the castle vagar had
come at last
and on her back road one eyed prince
eamonn he had not come alone
pregnant with his child alice rivers
flew with him
alice helped eamonn find daemon as she
saw him in the fire
the prince helped this woman down from
vegard's back
then turned to face his uncle calling
him a fool for coming to face him alone
because his dragon is the oldest
and the most powerful dragon on which
daemon replied were i not alone you
would not have come
finally eamon says to him you have lived
too long and daemon replies
on that much we agree before climbing
their dragons
when he climbed upon characters daemon
did not fast in his chains that
connected him
since daemon's dragon was a lot younger
and smaller than eamon's
daemon was quickly hidden in clouds
while eamonn looked for
him when characters attacked vulgar she
ripped up on his stomach and tore one of
his wings
but then characters fast and his jaws
surround her throat in death grip
these injuries force them both to cease
flying
and as they tumbled through the water
below daemond dueled eamonn to death
as he never fasted and his saddle daemon
stood up on charaxes
and lapped at aymond whereupon he drove
his dark sister through aemon's eye and
through his neck
just a second before hitting the water
the battle above the god's eye
ended in the deaths of both riders and
both the dragons
daemon was 49 when he died unlike
eamon's body however demons was never
found
singers say that damon lived to spend
the rest of his days in secret with
nettles
but most historians disagree i actually
believe daemon did not die here
and i have a good theory about it which
i will post in the following days
demon never achieved his ambition to sit
on the iron throne
though his son sagan iii and viserys ii
eventually did
in conclusion house of the dragon is
coming daemon targaryen will be one of
the main characters and probably my
favorite
just like here's george r martin's
favorite over the centuries house
targaryen has produced both great men
and monsters prince damon was both in
his day there was not a man so admired
so beloved
and so reviled in old westeros he was
made of light and darkness
in equal parts to some he was a hero to
others the blackest of villains
this is a good description of daemon the
best description comes from george r
martin of course i'm notorious for my
love of grey characters
and one of the greatest characters in
the entirety of westeros is damon
targaryen the rogue prince
uh we we took one of the sidebars and
made a separate story out of it the
rogue prince damon is
the younger brother of king viserys the
first for a time he was the heir to the
throne
when viscera's had no children and then
vasara started having children and he
stopped being the heir to the throne
he's a notorious bad boy
a rogue in every sense of the word he
was a rival
for the sarah's sister and his own niece
rhaenyra
and then later he became the husband of
rhaenyra he switches sides several times
you never know what side he's going to
come down
on he's a very colorful and
unpredictable character
and um i think he has to rank up there
as my favorite but the the book is full
of uh
what i hope are interesting characters i
honestly cannot wait for house of the
dragon
let me know which side you're on are you
supporting the greens or the blacks in
the targaryen civil war
thank you guys so much for watching i
hope you enjoyed this video and if you
did please give it a big thumbs up and i
hope to see you in the next one
peace